يشهد القطاع المصرفي في الاسواق العالميه
نزيفا مستمرا في اسعار الاسهم بسبب
تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي وبالرغم
من تطمنات الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن فقد
امتدت تاثيرات هذه الهزه الماليه الى دول
عده اذ اكدت شبكه ان 465 مليار دولار
تبخرت من الاسواق الماليه العالميه في
ثلاثه ايام فقط
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات سنبحث فيما مدى تاثير
انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي على البنوك
الامريكيه الاخرى وعلى القطاع المصرفي في
الاسواق العالميه ولماذا كانت مصارف شرق
اسيا الاكثر تضررا وما هي الارتدادات
السياسيه على اداره بايدن واجندتها على
المستويين الداخلي وكذلك الخارجي وما هي
خططها في مواجهه هذه التحديات وكيف نقرا
تصريحات الكريملين بان المصارف الروسيه
مؤمنه ثم هل تؤشر هذه التوجهات الى مرحله
جديده سيشهد فيها العالم ركودا اقتصاديا
امنيه مجرد سحابه صيف وكيف ستتاثر
بتداعيات هذه الازمه وما هي السبل للتخفيف
من وطاتها
[موسيقى]
عاصفه ماليه ذكرت كثيرين بازمه 2008
الماليه العالميه مشددين على ان ما يجري
حاليا يدل على الاخفاق في معالجه الجذور
العميقه لاسباب اضطراب الاسواق المصرفيه
وفي ظل المخاوف من انتشار عدوا انهيار
البنوك وانتقالها الى خارج الولايات
المتحده تراقب الدول الاوروبيه والاسيويه
عن كثب تراجع القيمه السوقيه للاسهم في
بورصاتها وسط ترقب لما سيتم اتخاذه من
اجراءات من قبل واشنطن وغيرها لتجنب
الاسوا
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور خليل العناني كبير الباحثين
بالمركز العربي في واشنطن ومعنا من لندن
الخبير في الشؤون الاقتصاديه نجاد اسماعيل
اهلا بكم وابدا بضيفي سيد نهاد اسماعيل
البعض يقارن ما جرى هذه المره بما حدث في
العام
2008 هل نحن امام سيناريو شبيه يختلف
نعم نعم ازمه الوقت الحاضر الان سيليكون
غالب بنك ليست كبيره بالحجم الذي تعرض له
الاقتصاد المالي الامريكي عام 2008 في ذلك
الوقت اثر الانصهار المالي على اكثر من
500 مصرف كانت الخساره العالميه عشره
تريليون دولار تبعت تلك الازمه ركود
اقتصادي
تاثرت البنوك الامريكيه ووافق الكونجرس
على تمويل قيمته 700 مليار دولار لانقاذ
النظام البنكي
وتداعيات 2008 استمرت حتى 2015
واطاحت بشركات كبرى مثل
بيرستانس كذلك لمن رفز واشنطن لذلك
المقارنه في الواقع هي غير واق عيه لان
حتى الان ماذا لو ادى ايضا الى ما يشبه
حركه الدومينو انتقل الى بنوك اخرى خاصه
هو الربط بان الذي حدث انما هو سببه
الارتفاع في الفائده وحجم التضخم
نعم لكن المره هذه المره تم اتخاذ اجراءات
سريعه حثيثه
لاحتواء الازمه تحرك الاحتياط على
الاتحادي بفتح خط تمويل للبنوك بحيث
يحصلون على قروض من الاحتياط الاتحادي
مباشره لكي يكفوا عن بيع سندات الخزينه
ويحقق
ويتكبدوا خسائر لانهم يبيعوها قبل تاريخ
الاستحقاق
ويعاني من ازمه سيوله كما حدث مع بنك او
مصرف وادي السيليكون وبنوك اخرى صغيره
دعني اقول ان السيليكون غالبا هذا ليس من
ركائز النظام المالي الامريكي او العالمي
هو بنك يتعامل بقطاع ضيق رغم انه مهم وهو
قطاع التكنولوجيا الحديثه للشركات النا
اعتقد نحن الازلنا في المرحله الاولى يا
استاذ عبد القادر لا يعني الوقت مبكرا حتى
نقول ان هذه ازمه ماليه سواء امريكيه او
عالميه حتى نتحدث عن انهيارات في ثلاث
بنوك بنوك من الحجم المتوسط الحجم الصغير
مثلا البنك الاول بنك هو راس مالو او
الصحوه9 مليار دولار وحجم ودائع به 175
مليار دولار هناك حجم هناك بنك حجم الاصول
به 110 مليار دولار حجم الودائع 88 88
مليار دولار وبنك سيلفر جيت وهو بنك متخصص
فيه اقراص الشركات العامله في مجال
العملات المشفره وديجيت وبالتالي بنوك
متوسط الحجم او صغيره الحجم دي نمره واحد
نمره اتنين حتى تحرك سريع جدا وحاسم
لاداره بايدن قامت بعده اجراءات اولا
عندما تم الكشف عن الازمه يوم الخميس
الماضي عندما قام المستثمرون بسحب حوالي
45 مليار دولار من اصول البنك وحدث او
تاثير العدوى وانهار البنك يوم الجمعه
قامت الاداره الامريكيه
بالاستحوا البنك والقيام بعده امور الامر
الاول هو اعتقد ضمانات للمودعين بان
اموالهم
اموالهم في امان قلت له هناك امكانيه
الاسترداديه من خلال وحدث بالفعل بالامس
فتم فتح الباب من اجل استرداد هذه الودائع
وهذه الاموال الامر الثاني وهو البدء في
تحقيقات مباشره حول هذه الازمه واليوم قبل
ساعتين فقط من الان اصدرت العهد الامريكيه
قرارا بالبدء التحقيق لان هناك شبهات
بقيام بعض المسؤولين في هذا البنك ببيع
اسهم شركه البنك قبل حوالي اسبوعين وثلاثه
من هذه الازمه هناك اجراءات فاعل الامر
الثالث متعلق بخطاب بيض بالامس بيض بالامس
خرج رئيس الامريكي خرج بالامس وطمئن
الاسواق وتطمئن المودعيه وطمئن وبالتالي
هناك اجراءات فاعله هذا المتوقع ان يتم
تاجيل اجتماع المركز الاحتياطي الفطار
الامريكي اللي هو الفيد الاسبوع القادم
لدى رفع الفائده كان هناك توقعات برفع
الفائده على الاقل نصف % طيب في الاسبوع
القادم كان هناك تنبات هذه اللحظه هذه
اللحظه بتاجيل اجتماع حتى وقت اخر ساعودك
يا دكتور لاسالك عن ان كانت هذه الطمئنه
من قبل البيت الابيض
اتت اكلها ام ما زالت المخاوف مرتفعه
ليعود الى ضيفي من لندن السيد نهاد فيما
يتعلق بحجم التاثير حتى الان وكاله
بلومبرت تتكلم عن ان اكثر من 465 مليار
دولار تبخرت من الاسواق العالميه بمجرد
الاعلان عن هذا الخبر وبالتالي ما مدى حجم
ما جرى
نعم نعم هذه كره الثلج التي
تنحدر وتكبر ولكن ليست بالشكل الذي
نعتقد حدث 2008 وهذا رد فعل بسبب المخاوف
من ركود اقتصادي مخاوف من ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده مخاوف من اتساع الازمه وكل هذه
الخسائر التي تكبدتها اسهم البنوك في
اوروبا وبريطانيا واسيا هي ربما يمكن
القول انها خسائر دفتريه او ورقيه يعني
عندما يستقر الامور ويتم احتواء الازمه
والاعلان ان الامور الان طبيعيه ويتم
اعاده اداره هذه البنوك بطريقه افضل
سترتفع الاسهم وسيتعافى الاقتصاد سوف لا
يكون لها اثر كبير طويل الامد خذ دول
الخليج مثلا اسهم بعض البنوك في دبي
في الامارات والكويت وغيرها نزلت باقل من
هبط باقل من واحد بالمئه في قطر واحد ونصف
بالمئه في السعوديه اقل من واحد بالمئه
لذلك التاثير سيكون محدود وضئيل وسوف لا
نرى هزاد ضخمه لكن المخاوف موجوده
والاضطراب في الاسواق والمخاوف من ارتفاع
اسعار الفائده التي تبطئ النمو الاقتصادي
هي ربما بعض الاسباب ولكن ليست لان بنك
سيليكون غالي انهار لاسباب داخليه بحته
وهي اداره البنك وقرارات استراتيجيه خاطئه
نتطرق لها لاحقا اذا اردت دكتور خليفه ما
ذكرته قبل قليل على ان الخطوات المتخذه من
قبل البيت الابيض قد تعيد الاستقرار على
الاقل النفسي من باب طمانه البنوك وطمانه
مدعين ماذا عن النقاش والجدل داخل على الا
تتدخل
الدوله كل مره لانقاذ الوضع وان تجد حلول
اخرى على ثانويه يتم شراء هذا البنك او
دمجه ماذا عن هذا الجدل ايضا في ظل ما زال
مساله ايضا رفع مزيد من سعر الفائده امر
وارد
هذا الجدل جزء رئيس من طريقه عمل نظام
الامريكي نظام الامريكي ليس نظاما براس
واحده فقط هناك عده سلطات سلطه التشريعيه
على اهم منها ماذا سلطتهم هناك دور مهم
جدا للمشارع لكن بشكل عام فهذه اللحظه
هناك الشعور كما قلت قبل قليل هناك نوع من
الاطمئنان قليلا نوعا ما على الاقل حتى
هذه اللحظه ليس هناك نوع من البانيك او
نوع من الذعر الموجود داخل الدوره
الامريكيه هناك بالقطع هناك يعني وسط
الجمهوريين مخاوف من التدخل الحكومه
الامريكيه وهذا يعتبر جوز رئيسي من طريقه
تفكير الجمهوريين لكن حتى هذه اللحظه هناك
سيطره للجمهور للديمقراطيين على مجلس
الشيوخ وبالتالي ليس هناك امكانيه
قد تؤدي من الحد من تدخل الحكومه لكن بشكل
عام هناك حديث جاري الان حول وضع ضابط
جديده قيود جديده على عمليه يعني استخدام
الاموال والاستثمار في الاموال خاصه فيما
يتعلق بطاعه التكنولوجيا وقطاع العملات
المشفره وهذا جزء من نقاش صحي موجود داخل
فقط يعني مع هذه الازمه حتى من قبل هذه
الازمه هناك حديث مستمر حول وابدا بعد
الضوابط بعض القيود على الاستثمار في بعض
مجال العملات المشفره وبالتالي هناك حديث
مستمر مساله الامر المتعلق بامكانيه تدحر
الكره الثلج يعني تكبر هذه الازمه لو ان
هناك بالفعل ازمه كبيره جدا هناك انهيارات
اخرى تحدث في لعب القادمه في بنوك اخرى في
مؤسسات ماليه اخرى قد يحدث نوع من تدخل
السريع من قبل كونجرس نفسه من اجل وقف هذه
المساله حتى لا تتكرر ما حدث في 2008 لكن
بشكل هذه اللحظه ليس هناك خلاف كبير بين
البيت الابيض من جهه وبين جهه الاخرى طيب
سيد نهاد فيما يتعلق بسريعا جاء رد فعل
الكريم باشارتك بان ما جرى حتى الان لن
يؤثر كثيرا على الاسواق العالميه سريعا
جاء بيان الكلام بان البنوك الروسيه محصنه
في حال حدوث اي انهيار متتالي بعد الذي
جرى في هذا البنك الامريكي
بشكل مبسط اقتصادي كيف يمكن ذلك
الاقتصاد الروسي هو اقتصاد على النظام
الشيوعي تديره الحكومه ولا يعمل
باستقلاليه ماء البنك المركزي يخضع للقرار
السياسي وتعليقات موسكو هي تعليقات في
الواقع السياسي كانها يعني سعيده
بالازمه الامريكيه لهذا امر سياسي لكن
الاقتصاد الروسي طبعا اقتصاد مسير ومدار
حكوميه الاقتصاد الامريكي اقتصاد راسمالي
هناك فصل للسلطات هناك استقلاليه هناك
نظام قانوني واضح وهناك تشريعات واضحه وكل
شيء فوق مفتوح
للمشاهد
وللمستثمر
ولكل من يرغب في الحصول على المعلومات لا
يمكن الحصول على معلومات بتلك السهوله في
الدول التي الشيوعيه مثل الصين وروسيا لا
يصلحون عن المعلومات بطريقه شفافه واضحه
لذلك اي شيء ياتي من موسكو يجب ان نتعامل
معه بحذر شديد في الواقع في هذه المرحله
خاصه
بالجدير بالذكر ان الرئيس بايدن كان قد
تعهد بما سماها المحاسبه فيما يتعلق
بالاضطرابات التي يشهدها القطاع المصرفي
بين حين واخر وفي اخر التطورات نقلت صحيفه
ان وزاره العدل ولجنه الاوراق الماليه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه شرعت في اجراء
تحقيق في انهيار بنك سيليكون وهنا اسال
دكتور خليل العدني فيما يتعلق بهذه
النقطه بين ان السبب الاساسي رفع الفائده
التضخم وبالتالي هذا سيقرا بطريقه ما وبين
الاشاره الى الشبهه الجنائيه ما الفرق
انا اعتقد هناك فرق فرق كبير جدا لما
بنتكلم على انه الجزء رئيسي من انهيار
البنك متعلق باستثماره في سندات طويله
المدى وبالتالي جاءت رفع الفائده فاتى الى
خسارات كبيره جدا على سبيل المثال مثلا
البنك خاسر عندما قام بيع اسهمه الاسبوع
الماضي خسر اكثر من اتنين مليار دولار في
اقل من ساعتين وبالتالي هناك جزء متعلق
بعدم قدره البنك على الاستثمار في في
سندات قصيره المدى وتاثر بشكل او باخر
بارتفاع الفائده الفائده في امريكا ارتفعت
على اقل سبع مرات في العام الماضي كانت
قبل او ايام كورونا كانت حوالي سفر في
المئه الان نتكلم على اربعه ونص في الميه
هناك كلام حاضر
المسؤول عن البنك بان هناك امكانيه لحدوث
انهيار قاموا ببيع اسهمهم في هذا البنك
يعتبر نوع من شبهه جنائيه لهناك نوع من
استغلال النفوذ داخل هذه الشركه التي تشرف
على البنك فيما يتعلق مكاسب وهناك امكانيه
للقيام بسجن بعض من توراه في هذه المساله
الى ثبت ان راكب الفعل تدخل من قبل في هذه
المساله وبالتالي الامر له بعدين بعد
اقتصادي متعلق بالاجواء العامه في امريكا
رفع سعر الفائده التضخم عدم وجود سيوله
ماليه كافره البنك ومن جهه اخرى متعلق
بشبهه فساد او على الاقل استغلال النفوس
من قبل البعض داخل البنك ما يتعلق خلال
فتره الماضيه
سيدنا ضيفي من لندن الان فيما يتعلق
بالمنطقه العربيه قلت قبل قليل بان لن
يكون هناك تاثير كبير وحتى الان المؤشرات
تقول او ترجح ما ذكرته الان هل هذا
السيناريو قائم في كل الحالات حتى ولو
تطور الامر الى ابعد من هذا البنك
نعم نعم اذا تطور الامر واتسع واتسعت رقعه
الازمه قد تؤثر اكثر لكن التاثير المباشر
الذي حدث هو ان اسعار النفط انخفضت اكثر
من خمسه بالمئه في اليومين الماضيين هذا
طبعا يؤثر على الدول المنتجه اسعار الاسهم
هبطت قليلا في مصر ثلاثه وربع بالمئه في
دول الخليج كما ذكرت سابقا بالنسبه اقل
بكثير ولكن اللي يجب القول ان لا يوجد
مصرف في المنطقه العربيه له علاقه مباشره
في مصرف سيليكون فالي لا يوجد علاقه ابدا
لذلك التاثير سيكون محدود وضئيل ولكن اذا
الازمه اتسعت وكبرت واصبحت ازمه ازمه ما
ازمه ماليه كبيره تؤثر على الدولار واسعار
الفائده وغير ذلك لان الاقتصادات العملات
العربيه في الخليج ترتبط بالدولار وكذلك
البنوك العربيه خاصه في منطقه الخليج ترفع
اسعار الفائده عندما يرفعها الاحتياطي
وتخفضها عندما يخفض بنسب متقاربه او حتى
نفس النسبه وهذا حدث في الشهور الاخيره
لذلك نعم هناك تاثير ولكن الاسماء حتى
الان هي محدوده ويمكن احتوائها بسبب
الاجراءات السريعه والنظم والتشريعات
والقواعد
الالمانيه الان في الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا واوروبا اشد كثيرا مما كانت
عليه عام 2008 لذلك سيتم احتواء الازمه
والنظام المالي العالمي سيبقى سليما لا
اتوقع كارثه كبرى حتى مثلا خذ
ذراع
بنك سيليكون فالي في في لندن تم احتواء
الازمه بسرعه وانتهى الموضوع
استلموا واشتراه والان يتم ادارته بطريقه
حسب الجدل داخل
من حقه وليس من اموال البريطانيين وهنا
اعود اسال ضيفي من واشنطن
فيما يتعلق بالتعاطي حتى الان اداره بايدن
مع هذا الحدث المالي المهم رغم ما ذكرتما
من محدوديته ما الذي حققته من النقاط
وما الذي تتلقته ايضا من اوجه انتقاد حتى
الان
بشكل عام هناك تحركا من قلت قبل قليل هناك
طمانه للاسواق خاصه للمدعين المستثمرين
هناك اجراءات تم اتخذها تم الاستحواذ
الحكومي على ثلاث ملوك حتى هذه اللحظه من
اجل طمانه الموادعين المستثمرين الامر
الثاني تم فتح تحقيق اليوم مع المسؤوليه
عن بنك سيليكون فالي هناك ايضا احتمال كما
قلت قبل قليل بتاجيل اجتماع البنك المركزي
الفيدرالي الامريكي من اجل رفع سعر
الفائده هناك تحرك على مستوى سواء من
الحكومه او من الكونجرس اجراءات تبث بشكل
ضخم من الطمانينه والثقه مهمه جدا وهي
عامل مهم جدا في الاقتصاد لو ان هناك ثقه
للمواطنين خاصه المسلمين المبدعين في
النظام المال والبنكي هناك نوع من
الارتياح وامكانيه حل الازمه هناك نوع من
الذعر او نوع من الخوف هناك عمليه رش او
او جري بشكل سريع من اجل سحب
المالي حتى هذه اللحظه هناك نوع من
التعاطي بكافه الانتقادات هناك انتقادات
بشكل او باخر حتى هذه اللحظه بانه كيف سمح
هذا البنك ان يقوم بهذه المساله اليس لك
رقابه كافيه خاصه من قبل السلطات
كاليفورنيا التي يقع في نطاقها البنك من
حيث السلطه القضائيه وسلطه القانونيه
والاشرافيه والرقابيه كيف وصلت الامور
لهذه المساله لهذا لهذه الدرجه وادى
لانهيار وهناك من خوف ايضا من يؤدي ذلك
الى ولا ياتي المساله المتعلقه بالتاثير
السلبي في هذه الازمه اليس الامر متعلق
بالبعد المالي فقط متعلق تكنولوجي بنك
التي تقوم باقراض ما يطلق عليه او الشركات
الناشئه خاصه
في حجم الانتاج التكنولوجي في امريكا
بتتكلم على امريكا انه اكبر دوله من
العالم في التكنولوجيا على مثلا
مايكروسوفت جوجل وشركات اخرى وبالتالي
هناك مخاوف من يؤدي انهيار هذا البنك الى
تباطؤ في القطاع التكنولوجيا وبالتالي قد
يؤدي ذلك الاثار عالميه وليس فقط داخل
امريكا وهذا ايضا ربما ايضا الى مساله
البنوك الاسيويه ايضا تاثرت بهذا
البنك ايضا اسرائيل من الدول التي تاثرت
بهذا البنك وهذا يحيلنا الى امتى تاثرت
هذه المنطقه ما يتعلق بالبنوك الاسيويه
الى اي مدى قد تؤثر على النشاط الاقتصادي
العالمي حجم الركود في الاقتصاد العالمي
وسؤال هنا لضيفي السيد نهاد اسماعيل
باختصار لو تكرمت
نعم نعم طبعا
ولكن علينا القول ان بنك سيليكون فاني
استفاد كثيرا من الكوفيد 19 لانها كسر
كثره الشركات التي تقدم خدمات ترفيهيه
وتسليه والعاب كمبيوتر وغيرها خلال هذه
الفتره ارتفعت الودائع ارتفع الاستثمار
ارتفعت القروض وكذلك ارتفع اسهم الشركه
ولكن هذا النهار بسبب اخطاء استراتيجيه
ارتكبت
الكريم الى بعضها الان في اسيا طبعا هي
منكشفه على الاقتصاد الامريكي والدولار هي
العمله الرئيسيه التي تتعامل بها رغم
اليوان من
الروبلر يبقى سيد الموقف وهذا طبعا سيؤثر
على
شؤون الاقتصاديه لهذا اسماعيل شكرا لك
وكذلك رضيفي من واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني كبير الباحثين بالمركز العربي في
واشنطن
ختام هذه الحلقه من برنامج الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]